One long molecule, spiraling around
in a double helix.
Exquisite, ordered, simple
and regular.
Two strands of nucleotides,
each with a strong backbone
composed of sugar and phosphate.
With what we call nucleotide bases
on the inside:
Adenine, 'A',
guanine or 'G', cytosine, 'C',
and thymine or 'T'.
And these bases always pair together, according to some simple rules.
A always pairs with T,
and C always pairs with G.
These four bases make up an alphabet
of four letters, the genetic code.
And that is the key, DNA is a code.
A code that holds all the information
to make all living things.
Somehow, DNA must tell each
and every cell in the body
what it is to become,
and when and where.
But how?
1950s scientists had a big job to do,
they had to crack the code.
So if you consider how a code works,
let's think it out.
We've got four bases,
and we need to make
20 different amino acids.
So if we have a code that
just consists of one base,
we could only make four possible
amino acids, right, which isn't enough.
So if we had a code that consisted
of two bases
that could get together
in any combination,
how many different amino acids
could we make then?
Yes, 16, exactly.
It's not enough is it, we need 20.
so if we had a code
based on three bases,
that could get together
in any combination,
how many amino acids
could we produce then?
Nine? Not quite... yes, 64, exactly.
More than nine
and more than we need.
So three bases would work.
And that's exactly what scientists
found to be the case,
they worked out the code
and they worked out
that it was arranged in
threes, a triplet code,
with each group of three bases
called a codon.
And each group of three bases
or codon specifies or codes
for a particular amino acid.
So we can see that here,
here's a codon of three bases
and that will give us an amino acid,
which we give another single letter code to.
We needn't worry about
the amino acid code for now.
Here's another codon, CCC,
that gives us this amino acid, P.
And here's another codon GAA,
that gives us that amino acid, E.
So we can start to decode
this DNA sequence
and turn it into
an amino acid sequence,
so we can see a growing
amino acid chain in a protein.
Now I'm not going to waste my time
decoding all of that.
Now we've got one here
that we prepared earlier,
we know it's the same,
this is all these nucleotides,
all these codons
decoded into these amino acids.
So here is our protein chain.
So a protein is like a sentence
of amino acid letters,
and you can even see
that we've got some punctuation
in our sentences,
because it turns out
that there are special codons
that make something like a full stop
at the end of the protein.